je vais vous parler tout à l'heure de
l'ancien président Valéry Giscard
d'Estaing qui se trouve en ce moment en
visite en Israël une visite privée à
l'invitation d'un publiciste français
hier monsieur Giscard d'estain a été
reçu par le Président de la République
israélienne puis par le chef du
gouvernement Patricia charnel
c'est sans doute cette scène ce matin au
mur des lamentations qui a le plus
frappé les observateurs du voyage de
Valéry Giscard d'Estaing un accueil
chaleureux de la population qui
contraste avec l'impopularité de
l'ancien président en Israël quand il
était au pouvoir en France
dialogue également et c'est la partie
officielle du voyage avec les
responsables politiques
là aussi il apparaît que les discussions
ce sont déroulées dans un bon climat
exemple ce matin l'entretien avec le
Premier ministre israélien
est-ce que vous considérez monsieur
Giscard d'Estaing comme un ami d'Israël
il faut dire aussi que Valéry Giscard
d'Estaing est en Israël au moment où un
débat très sérieux se déroule entre les
responsables aussi bien sur la crise
économique que sur les problèmes de
sécurité la guerre au Liban la question
palestinienne n'ont jamais autant
interpellé et dans certains cas diviser
les Israéliens et c'est au sein même de
l'acnécette le parlement israélien que
Valéry Giscard d'Estaing a rappelé ses
positions
il doit y avoir de la part de la France
bien entendu une conscience très vive du
problème de la sécurité d'Israël c'est à
la fois un problème en raison de la
situation géographique du pays mais
c'est aussi un problème psychologique et
politique plus profond c'est la très
longue histoire des souffrances et des
épreuves du peuple d'Israël qui font que
ce problème de
sécurité à une dimension particulière et
enfin il faut avoir une vue directe
franche du problème palestinien lorsque
nous circulons même ici dans la ville
nous rencontrons la vue ce matin des
Arabes palestiniens la présence de ces
Palestiniens de Laura Palestiniens et
sensible dans toute une partie du pays
et notamment la solution du problème
palestinien fait partie de des
conditions fondamentales de la paix dans
la région
à la fin de la semaine Valéry Giscard
d'Estaing international